welcome back to the stronger buy science
podcast we've got a great episode this
week
we've got a couple research review
segments where we look at the effects of
high protein diets on kidney function
also a research review looking at the
effects of dietary cholesterol intake
on training adaptations we then do a
question and answer segment where we
talk a lot about central nervous system
fatigue
and for some reason we had plenty of
whale related content this week
as always thank you for listening and we
hope you enjoy the episode
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your host eric trexler
and today
i'm joined by a very special very
temporary guest host named greg knuckles
greg
thank you for joining me how are you
doing today i'm doing well how are you
i am doing quite well uh we've got a lot
of stuff to get to
today but before we do that uh just a
quick reminder to listeners be sure to
join our facebook group
be sure to join our subreddit and be
sure to join in on the
newsletter email list if you are
interested in
signing up for any of those the the
links are in the description
of today's episode i also want to sell
out very quickly before we get into
today's content so
selling out segments in the past i've
talked about um
using bulksupplements.com for all your
supplement needs
typing in code sbs pod in all caps when
you check out to save five percent
up to this point my marketing strategy
has been to focus on the
considerable wealth that one could build
with that five percent savings but
you know realistically our listeners
it's an altruistic bunch
and i don't know if that messaging is
really getting through to them so i want
to take a different
uh a different approach this week so are
you familiar with five percent nutrition
company i don't think so uh it's rich
piana oh
his his company oh man our r.i.p to rich
i had uh how long ago was that like two
or three years i had completely
i'd completely forgotten about five
percent nutrition so
the website's still going strong and
they've got something about the five
percent lifestyle
and the way they put it is being willing
to sacrifice what the other 95
of the population won't do in pursuit of
your goals
so what i want i want to frame our
messaging differently i want to ask
our listeners are you willing to
sacrifice the extra 95
of your money to personally prop up the
stronger by science empire
i can't answer that question for you you
have to look within yourself
okay all right greg let's go uh let's
move on to the good news segment what do
we got today
uh yeah so um
i found a story about a dog
that uh you know wasn't in good shape to
begin with
it was adopted the people that found it
it was still a puppy and pretty much on
the verge of death
which is very much not the situation you
want a dog to be in
but it turns out this dog has
a very keen nose and an
exceptionally high toy drive so the
dog's name is
eba uh now lives somewhere on the west
coast
they found her in uh in sacramento
and so they're putting this dog's high
toy drive and good nose to use for
whale conservation um so
where this dog currently lives there's a
pod
of orca whales that are apparently not
in great shape
and a key piece of whale conservation
is being able to locate their scat
or their poop so they can study you know
what the whales are eating and
generally if they're in good health or
not apparently you can tell that from
poop
um and uh this dog
iba is apparently just very very good at
locating whale poop with her very
sensitive nose
uh and where toy drive comes into this
is that
you know the dog apparently isn't like
super keen on finding whale [ __ ]
uh but it likes playing with toys and so
they've learned
like they've taught the dog to associate
like you find whale poop you can play
with toys for like 10 minutes
uh so that's kind of the compensation
structure they're working with
uh for this dog and uh yeah eba
little rescue dog uh helping save the
whales
very good and i'm gonna continue with
the animal theme which has been carried
on for several weeks now
uh fiona the hippo at the cincinnati zoo
celebrated her first birthday uh a
lovely cause for celebration
uh the cincinnati zoo has a special
place in my heart growing up as a kid
spent some time there
uh and zoos zoos can be very hit or miss
you know if you go to a nice well-funded
zoo
it's a lovely experience the animals are
happy they're treated well
if you go to a a zoo that's not in great
shape it's like one of the worst days of
your life
it is not a fun experience but the
cincinnati zoo has always been really
solid
uh and yeah as a kid spent some good
times there uh it's uh they let the
little peacocks walk around
so you're walking around they're not in
an exhibit they're just hanging out with
you oh nice yeah it's pretty cool
um he's here at the north carolina zoo
they used to do that
by accident with canadian geese uh
and if if you're going to have fouls
walking around with you i'm going to
assume
peacocks are better zoo companions than
canadian geese
yeah they just kind of wanted to show
off their cool feathers and hang out
that was pretty much it nice but yeah
cincinnati zoo
had some bad press with the whole
harambe situation
oh that was cincinnati that was
cincinnati so it's good to see
fiona stole the show and everyone you
know was like oh hey
what a lovely operation they're running
over there she had her first birthday
there was a party there was a cake made
out of watermelon
which is very fascinating i've spent a
lot of time doing some different
culinary creations i left desserts off
the table
now i've got a lot of creative juices
flowing i'm thinking
how might i arrange fruit such that they
are essentially i don't know a
cheesecake
i mean there's there's a lot of areas i
know with that so keep an eye out for
that that's going to be my next
batch of recipes is probably going to be
just saying that fruit is dessert
oh speaking of which uh i guess this is
kind of good newsie um
eric i actually need to thank your
girlfriend live on the air uh last night
uh my wife and i lindsey we started
watching the great british baking show
which your girlfriend has been
recommending to us for months
uh the only thing i can say is she
should have been more insistent with the
recommendation
because honestly that's the most
delightful [ __ ] show i've ever seen
it's awesome i don't know there's not
enough backstabbing there's not enough
yelling and
and fighting well i mean
to each their own yeah i like the old uh
the
gordon ramsay approach to cooking you
know if nobody's crying nobody's cooking
have you seen
um have you ever seen a super cut of
like gordon ramsay's british shows
versus american shows cause like
he does also do food competitions on
british television
and generally like the premise of it is
very similar as well
but and and i think also god i'm
forgetting
which show it was because he's had like
a dozen at this point
but one of his shows uh simultaneously
aired
in both america and great britain um
and just like the the way it was cut and
the editing of it just turned it into
two completely different programs
uh like the american version was just
all like
people screwing up and gordon ramsay
swearing
and uh like you know music that
indicates that something bad is
currently happening or about to happen
and the british version of the same show
was just like oh here are some very
competent cooks
cooking things generally pretty well
sometimes they mess up and gordon gives
them pointers but it
i mean like he was still much more
critical and aggressive than mary berry
is um
but like just the whole vibe is
completely different apparently american
audiences
are just really into british people
being [ __ ]
but i mean the formula worked for
american idol you know why why
ruin it that's true um all right so uh
let's move on we got uh feats of
strength
yeah so um only have one this week
uh so a 16 year old lifter named malik
troilet from france so i'm probably
mispronouncing that name horribly um
he recently put up a gym total of 705
kilos or
1554 pounds at a body weight of 82 kilos
or 182 pounds
which is really strong regardless of how
old someone is
it's 16 that's crazy so
that would put him second all time in
that age and weight division
um so the current record is 708 kilos so
three kilos off of that um but the thing
about teenagers i don't think a lot of
people know this
generally you just get stronger
naturally from uh
you know puberty uh so this kid's 16
he's probably gonna take the record uh
before he turns 18
very very strong though very impressive
lifting
good stuff all right so we've got a
couple research review
segments today so i've got one and
you've got one
my research review segment is about the
effects of high protein diets
on kidneys and uh before i get into it
i just want to be totally transparent
probably the worst kept secret in the
world exercise physiologists
avoid renal stuff like the plague
we don't like it we understand it's
important
you'd rather have kidneys than not have
kidneys in terms of being a human being
but it's like so back in the day
universities operated in person and
you'd have to be there and give a
lecture
every guest lecture i've ever heard of
when when someone's trying to teach
physiology in an exercise department
the guest lecturer you are always going
to go teach their kidney unit
they will never be like hey can you come
teach my students about
the heart or skeletal muscle they're
like no i like that stuff
if you ever do a guest lecture you're
either teaching about the kidneys or the
lungs
and that's it so it's the number one
guest
guest lecture topic by a mile because
nobody wants to deal with the
intricacies of kidney function because
it's complicated
kidneys are pretty complicated so i i
gotta tell you um
i think in terms of like anatomy and
physiology
i think i may have learned uh kidney
like renal physiology better than like
pretty much any other organ system
because my anp2 professor
just really had a thing for kidneys
and the reason for that he he was way
more transparent about this than i wish
he would have been
but uh he apparently just had like
a huge history of kidney stone issues uh
and also was just like really into
learning about anything related to urine
because he also was way more transparent
about this than i would have wanted him
to be
apparently had a [ __ ] prostate the
size of a cantaloupe
uh told us about that the first day of
class
which i didn't need to know about but
anyway
uh he knew a lot about kidneys because
that was that was something that
mattered a lot to him as a person
and so uh yeah a p2 we really really got
into the kidneys
and he had way more kidney-related
anecdotes than
i think any of us wanted to hear but i
think that helped like
sear the information into our minds a
little bit better
yeah yeah whatever you didn't
protectively block out of your mind
you really retained uh no i mean that's
good a lot of exercise physiology
professors got into it because they're
really into
cranking up your vo2 max getting strong
getting muscular
not a lot of people who focus on the
kidney and the kidney like i said very
complicated but
the impetus for this research review
segment uh someone in the stronger by
science subreddit
the user's name was the one who choose i
believe
um shared a couple studies there were
there was a
grouping of two studies and a commentary
about those two studies all within the
same issue of a journal
and the journal is nephrology uh
dialysis
and transplantation and so all three of
you know the two studies in the
commentary we're basically all looking
at
the effect of uh protein intake on
kidney function specifically looking at
um the glomerular filtration rate
so we're going to call that gfr from
this point forward because
glomerular not easy to say quickly and
many times over
so i didn't mess it up yet and we'll
leave it there so gfr
uh is really the main marker of kidney
function that's being
looked at in these studies now a couple
disclaimers i am not a medical doctor
and i am not a kidney researcher so uh
you know
take this stuff with a grain of salt but
i kind of just looked at these studies
and said let's
remember the research fundamentals and
see what we can make of them here
and honestly i was so surprised by
the divergence between my interpretation
and the conclusions or like the general
premise here
i honestly feel like i'm wrong like i
feel like i'm missing something
but but we'll get into it and we'll
decide if if uh
if i'm just way off base here or if
maybe some of these
conclusions are overly simplistic so
the first study do you first want to
just walk through
walk people through what gfr is and like
why it's
relevant in the first place well you're
the kidney expert why don't you do it
oh god um yeah so
basically like all of your blood is
circulating around your body
uh and it goes through your kidneys
pretty frequently i think your kidneys
filter all of your blood about once
every five minutes give or take
um and so the
you have like little contraptions
basically within your kidneys called
glomeruli
uh and as your blood is going through
your kidneys
it goes into little capillaries and
basically like everything like a lot of
the stuff in your blood gets forced into
the glomeruli
uh and then from there it's filtered so
basically the way the kidneys work is
pretty much everything is forced from
your blood into the glomeruli
and then as all of that stuff passes
through the glomeruli
it's reabsorbed back into your blood if
it needs to be
or if it doesn't need to be it filters
out and then goes into your urine
and you excrete it and so gfr is
basically just a measure of
the rate at which things are being
processed through the glomeruli
as your blood is filtered through your
kidneys
theoretically but this first study by
g and colleagues they they had over 9
000 subjects it was more of an
epidemiology type study
mean age of participants was 52 years
in this particular study whenever you
look at epidemiological approaches to
this
they usually use estimated glomerular
filtration rate so the estimated gfr
and in some cases which is the case in
this first study it's essentially
purely a measure of serum creatinine and
age
so they take your serum creatinine they
put your age into this big equation and
they get your gfr
now obviously that's whenever you're
looking at a study like this you don't
have to just say what is the construct
we're talking about but
literally what is being measured and so
in this case we're talking specifically
about
serum creatinine which is impacted by
the intake of animal protein i mean if
if you have a you know really large
increase in your
intake of animal protein your serum
creatinine is going to go up
fully independent of kidney function um
and then of course create
creatinine is affected by several other
things as well activity level
is one of them acutely so that's a huge
caveat to keep in mind before you even
get into the details of this study is
that we're really just
looking at a rough estimate of gfr based
on
serum creatinine now
gfr also goes down
with age naturally even if your kidneys
are functioning the way
totally normal healthy kidneys function
so if we're talking
about somebody that's 20 to 29 gfr is
probably going to be about 116
or so uh 30 to 39 we're talking about
107
and then it starts to really decline
decade over decade and we're talking
about each decade seeing
reductions of six eight maybe ten units
uh per decade
okay so about one or two units per year
roughly and it's not a linear
relationship the older we get
gfr really starts to to drop off and
that's
that's what we sign up for with aging um
when we talk about
chronic kidney disease which is where a
lot of the protein
research that's really what they're
trying to make a lot of inferences about
is your risk of developing chronic
kidney disease usually you don't start
worrying about that
until gfr gets below 60.
so so like i said younger folks it's
usually up
90s 100 and above and then once it
starts
getting below 60 we're talking about
chronic kidney disease once it starts
getting below
30 we're talking about really getting
concerned about kidney function
and then if you're below 15 we're
talking about end stage renal failure
at that point now it would be
inappropriate to say that you always
want gfr to be higher
so there is something called hyper
filtration
which is when the number is actually a
little bit too high
and one of the reasons you might be
concerned about that is you know
theoretically if you're in this state of
hyper filtration
that can actually directly damage the
kidneys uh in a
what what a lot of papers say is an
irreversible manner
so i don't know there's probably like
you know if i'm sure researchers are
arguing over whether or not it's
reversible i have no idea but the
consensus that you see in the papers is
that damage tends to be irreversible and
so if we are in this state of
really extreme hyper filtration and
we're damaging the kidney
then we'll start to see gfr actually
going down
as kidney function becomes impaired
due to that that predisposing damage
okay so
or the the preceding damage so when we
look at this first study
by uh by g and colleagues uh like i said
the the mean age was 52 years
and when we look at someone who's 50 to
59 years old we would expect
gfr about 93 give or take just based on
you know a table i found on the internet
surely it wouldn't lead me astray but um
in this study the the baseline values
they divided up the sample into
first second third and fourth quartile
so the lowest
25 of protein intakes and then the
second lowest
and then the you know second highest and
then the highest uh
protein intakes looking at those
quartiles
the baseline uh gfr
93.7 93.9 94
94.2 now theoretically we're looking at
people who are in these quartiles
because that is their habitual intake
it's not like they are being assigned to
something new
once you know this isn't like an
intervention where we're gonna mess with
their protein intake so
just right off the bat we're talking
about people in their 50s
and every single quartile here looks
really really normal in terms of gfr so
so that's one thing to look at is
right off the bat you know when a lot of
people ask these questions about protein
intake
the root uh impetus for the question is
by eating a high protein diet am i
screwing myself over in terms of kidney
function
just looking at the baseline numbers and
not looking any deeper
the highest quartile the lowest quartile
the middle quartiles
on average everybody's looking pretty
okay now
in terms of some actual uh kind of
findings of the study
you know the researchers noted that the
the mean rate of gfr decline
annually was faster as quartiles of
protein intake
increased so the higher quartiles had
more rapid reductions in gfr year over
year
than the lower quartiles but when we
look at the actual
mean rate of decline in these quartiles
you know first to fourth 2.01
2.05 2.19 2.34
these are pretty similar numbers uh you
would not look at that difference from
going from you know
2.01 to 2.05 quartile to quartile and
say man
that second quartile would really
benefit from dropping that
and even at the extremes of it 2.01 to
2.34
like i said i mean just with with
typical aging those are very
normal-ish looking numbers as far as i
can tell not an expert clinician but
those seem pretty pretty similar
and i found in a completely separate
paper they were talking about using some
of these creatinine based metrics
for um you know for looking at gfr
and they laid out an example so in this
other paper they mentioned you
hypothetically you've got a 60 year old
man with a serum creatinine of 0.7
milligrams per deciliter a 0.1 milligram
per deciliter change
would result in a 13.6 percent change in
the estimated gfr value so
it might change that gfr value from 88.5
to uh to 76.5 that is an enormous
drop and so when we're looking at
something as variable as creatinine
and we're looking at these really small
differences from quartile to quartile
that's
probably an important thing to keep in
mind and the
the main point that these authors in
this other paper we're trying to make is
that
it's really hard for a clinician to
really detect a meaningful change with
this
these creatinine uh based uh gfr numbers
just because the noise of fluctuating
creatinine can be so immense
one other thing that just jumps out to
me a little bit just looking at these
raw
numbers is in that table you have here
in the outline
showing that basically decade over
decade uh
once people reach 50 years old their
estimated gfr drops like 8 to 10 points
per decade
something like that um and all of these
groups it's saying
like two points per year so it's
basically saying that like
people in all four quartiles like in
this data set
were losing estimated gfr at basically
twice the rate that would be predicted
by age alone
that's a good point um when you look at
that rate of reduction it is a little
bit larger than you would expect
um not astronomically so but but it is
it is larger than you'd expect that's a
good point
i'm not gonna look too far into that
just because
um you know the gfr measurement itself
does tend to be fairly imprecise and
fairly
fickle um so you know if it was you know
10
times larger than we would expect that's
where i where i would look at and say
what in the world happened here these
numbers are a little bit larger than we
would expect but
i'm kind of comfortable accepting them
at face value and kind of moving forward
with the overall interpretation of the
paper
but yeah so looking at those annual
rates of decline
you know 2 2.3
not really huge differences from from
quartile to quartile
now another thing that they mentioned in
this paper by
g and colleagues is that the highest
quartile
was associated with a higher risk of of
rapid gfr decline so they kind of
created their operational definition
they they set a threshold and they said
if your annual uh reduction in gfr is
greater than you know this cut off then
we're going to say you have a rapid
decline
in gfr so so they said that the the
highest quartile
was associated with a a 1.3 fold
increased risk of experiencing this
rapid drop
in gfr but that was based on
a model with a bunch of different
covariates in the mix
when you look at just a really
simplistic view what were the raw
number of cases of who had this
rapid gfr decline from quartile to
quartile
in the first quartile 17.7 percent of
participants
met that threshold for a rapid drop of
gfr
in the second quartile 15.1 percent
third quartile 15.4
fourth quartile 15.6 so
just based on a really crude look at it
you say which quartile
in which quartile was the prevalence of
this rapid gfr
drop uh highest it was actually the
first quartile
and it wasn't until you start really
throwing a bunch of other covariates
into the model do we start to see that
things start shifting a little bit and
and it looks more like the higher
quartile number is experiencing more of
this reduction
in gfr so i think it's always critical
whenever you look at these epi-type
papers
it's not to say that that there's no
room for these covariates
in these epidemiological models but you
have to be really cautious about
forgetting that the raw numbers exist
and forgetting that the crude model
exists with no covariance yeah i mean
like ultimately if you're interested in
the effects of protein intake on a
particular outcome
and you have enough going into your
model that
like literally anything other than
protein intake is what's
driving what your model spits out like
it's not necessarily bad but like it's
worth at least
taking a peek at it to see what's going
on under the hood
yeah i mean so i i've done an
epidemiology
epidemiology type project before and we
presented the crude model with no
covariates and then we presented the
model with
the covariates that we thought were were
meaningful would be
you know important to include and the
actual effect estimates
changed a little bit but i mean we're
talking about an increased risk of
oh it's in this model it was 31 in this
model it was 26
we're not talking about creating a
linear relationship where once there was
none
yeah and so that's a whenever you see a
model where the crude numbers
like like i said getting back to the the
just original question
if i eat a high protein diet am i likely
to have you know this
really wonky gfr number based on
everything we're seeing
so far in the crude numbers this higher
quartile group is not any worse off than
any of the other quartiles and i mean
based on this particular outcome
the highest prevalence was in the lowest
quartile group
so um another thing that came up in the
paper
uh and this was the the high number that
tends to get a lot of attention
they looked at the relative risk of
having hyperfiltration
uh based on what quartile you were in
and they noted that the
uh the relative risk of having
hyperfiltration was
about three and a half times uh you know
3.5
fold higher in the highest quartile
group compared to the lowest quartile
group for protein
but again getting back to the raw
numbers which is an important starting
point whenever you look at this type of
epi epi research
the prevalence of hyper filtration first
quartile the fourth
5.2 percent four percent 5.2 percent and
6
so yes the the highest percentage
value was in the highest quartile but
you can't really talk about the alarming
increase from 5.2 to 6
without talking about the larger
reduction from 5.2 to 4
from the first quartile to the second
right and and so
when we look at what's even going on
there because it looks to me like a
approximately 1.15 fold increase in risk
not 3.48
well is that also just like a bunch of
other [ __ ] going into the
going into the model it's a bunch of
other [ __ ] going into the model
making a 15 increase risk approximately
start looking like a 248
increase risk yes holy [ __ ] so
that that's why i always say like look
at the crude numbers did they talk about
what
what was going into it like is it just
the fact that like the lowest
protein intake group was also doing a
bunch of other unhealthy [ __ ] so it's
like
when we adjust for that ultimately it
looks better
so both of these papers had a number of
different models with a variety of
different covariates
which is pretty common they'll say
here's model one where we put in these
things here's model two where we put in
all those things
and i'll be honest i'm not a gfr expert
to the to the extent that i would say oh
i know exactly which covariate in the
model is is
is is interfering with this relationship
between you know
protein intake and the incidence of or
the prevalence of hyperfiltration
but again everyone who asked this
question is asking
if i'm a person who eats high protein am
i inherently screwed
and looking at these numbers you don't
start to see anything alarming until
you're like
okay i understand you eat a lot of
protein but what's your education status
you know how many units of alcohol do
you drink per week
but ultimately that's that's not what
anyone in the fitness space is asking
they're asking are people who eat a lot
of protein inherently worse off
and i think the raw numbers are as
helpful if not more helpful for
answering that question
because when someone asks that question
they're not saying hey i eat a lot of
protein also
here's my income here's my education
status i smoked for a while when i was
younger but not anymore
and i have seven units of alcohol per
week like
that's not what anyone's asking yeah
they're not like yeah
what if i triple my protein intake but
like stop using a bunch of heroin
like what what's that gonna do exactly
um
and so looking at hyperfiltration um you
know
when we look at uh they kind of
separated out these groups
and said um you know uh here's the hyper
filtration group
here's the the group that doesn't have
hyperfiltration
uh the the mean reduction in gfr
annually was about 3.1 per year in the
hyper filtration group
and their their intake of protein was
was
1.07 grams per kilogram of of ideal body
weight
when they when they looked at the
non-hyper filtration group
instead of a 3.1 reduction per year it
was only 2.1
per year but
you know their mean protein intake was
1.02
grams per kilogram of ideal weight so
you know we're talking about this
theoretical
idea that having a high protein intake
is really meaningfully
influencing your risk of whether or not
you fall in the hyperfiltration group or
not
but when we look at the mean intake from
one group to the other it's
1.07 versus 1.02 very very similar
meaning
mean values so again you you look at
these numbers
in totality and where you might find a
particular model that gives you this
particular risk elevation that as a
percentage looks scary
just looking at the entire body of
evidence in this paper i don't see
enough here that
would lead me to believe that high
protein intakes are inherently scary
are inherently driving a huge reduction
in gfr year over year
or are inherently dictating whether or
not you're in the ar in the hyper
filtration group
so another thing that they brought up
was that
they did contextualize it a little bit
and they said when we looked at the
hyperfiltration group versus the
non-hyperfiltration group
the highest quartile in those with
hyperfiltration
seemed to be particularly bad in terms
of the rate of of decline
in in gfr over year year over year
and so so they're basically saying if
you if you have hyper filtration
you the the higher protein intake
intakes do seem to be having a pretty
notable impact on your rate of decline
year over year
whereas if you don't have
hyperfiltration maybe it wasn't quite as
impactful
i wanted to dig into that deeper because
the odds ratio was pretty high it looked
like a big number
so the odds ratio was 3.35
but the confidence interval was like
1.07 to 10.5
that that's a very uncertain estimate i
mean that that's a very wide confidence
interval
so i wanted to dig in deeper and really
the
the um the details for this particular
comparison came down to a figure
and it was like figure 3a versus 3b and
in the published paper they're literally
the same thing so
like there was like a editorial mistake
or something
but i wanted to compare this figure to
that figure this group to that group
but i'm almost certain that they were
just literally identical figures
so so you can't really dig deeper on
that one you just kind of have to take
their word for it
so that was the first study that was
pretty much what the results looked like
with the right covariates added into the
model some things that looked a little
bit scary
but i mean when you look at the raw
values did the people who eat a lot of
protein
seem worse off at baseline or over time
from my perspective not really now the
second study was by esmeyer
and colleagues had about two thousand
twenty two hundred
uh patients who had previously had uh
myocardial infarction uh had a heart
attack
and uh the mean age of this group was
sixty-nine
so already we're looking at
a special population people who have had
myocardial infarction and a much older
sample on average than the previous
study
um one thing i liked about this study is
they used a different method for for
estimating gfr they used one that was
based on
serum levels of cystatin c rather than
creatinine alone
um and they did a couple different
analysis one was just based on
the statin sea levels the other was a
different equation that uses creatinine
and cyst and c and overall the
differences between those two different
approaches seem pretty
pretty negligible within this particular
sample
so uh one thing i found interesting was
uh
in the introduction of this paper they
mentioned that for post myocardial
infarction patients
uh the annual rate of of kidney function
decline
per year is usually about two units
in when we're talking about uh gfr so
we're expecting kind of like
you know two year over year um
if we pretend it's linear it's not quite
linear but that's kind of what we're
going in
that's the expectation the expectation
that we're we're going in with
now the results uh their their analysis
indicated that
um for each incremental increase in
daily protein intake
of 0.1 grams per kilogram of ideal body
weight
the uh the additional reduction in uh
their the an
uh annual gfr change was a reduction of
0.12
units per year uh so the higher your
protein intake
you know the the more of a reduction
you'd see in that value
but when they stratified it so they
looked at patients who their protein
intake was greater than 1.2 grams per
kilogram
versus those who were under 0.8 grams
per kilogram
they found that the annual rate of
decline was about two times faster
in the higher protein group but when you
look at the
the actual rate of decline it was minus
1.6 per year versus
minus 0.84 per year and so
you know with the previous study you
mentioned those numbers were looked a
little bit higher than we would expect
in this particular study both of these
seem to be lower than
what we kind of signed up for on the
front end like we were kind of expecting
a reduction of
of two per year and it looks like the
high protein group and the low protein
group
in both instances we were under that
that two number so it
it doesn't look like the high protein
group was like wow look at this
elevation and risk it's more
this low protein group seems to have a
really low rate of decline year over
year
uh you know in this particular
population post myocardial infarction
you'd expect it to be about twice the
general population
and i mean this is actually lower than
you'd expect you know in in the typical
population i think
or at least very much on par with it so
um when we when we look at the baseline
gfr levels
stratified by intake so they have these
four different groups that they kind of
split up
less than 0.8 grams per kilogram 0.8 to
1
1 to 1.2 and then greater than 1.2 grams
per kilogram
um you know looking at the numbers the
the the gfr rates 77 80 83
85 again within a tight range
very similar to what we would expect as
being pretty normal based on their age
you know like i said this was an
older sample those were the numbers
based on statin c
when they use the other method that
incorporates creatinine values as well
we're talking about 75 77 79 82
so a little bit higher in the higher
protein quartiles but
everybody looks pretty normal and we're
not seeing a spread of numbers that
would seem to be
clinically super relevant and that
brings me to another thing
which is when i was looking through a
lot of this
renal literature it's
it's hard to tell when they want the
number to be higher or lower
so in in this instance we're talking
about the rate of decline year over year
right
and these are older folks and the
highest numbers are
are observed when we look at the raw
numbers in the people with the highest
protein intake
and so a lot of these papers are framed
as we want to
in terms of like baseline gfr right yeah
yeah baseline gfr so a lot of these
papers are written
with the the kind of general vibe that
we want to keep it high
because it goes down you know year over
year
but then like i said we also worry about
hyper filtration
we don't want it to be super super high
and what i found really
interesting is a nice way to put it
i've seen protein papers in this kidney
area where they see this clinically
clinically like pretty meaningless
increase in gfr
in response to protein and they say oh
man that's bad because if we extrapolate
that
i mean that's a one-way ticket to hyper
filtration and then they're going to
damage their kidney and then gfr is
going to just
fall off a cliff so if it goes up a
little bit within the normal range they
kind of catastrophize about it
but then if it goes down a little bit
within the normal range they're like oh
we're too late they're already you know
we're seeing them in this precipitous
downfall
their kidney's already shot it's just a
matter of time until it's end stage
renal failure
and so i i kind of don't know what you
want here
like we're seeing a lot of numbers that
are in pretty normal ranges for people's
age
and whether it goes up a tiny bit or
down a tiny bit i've seen papers
indicating that both are a disaster
which just doesn't really make sense to
me well it sounds like having your cake
and eating it too
like you can uh you can
open up a data set and if your
hypothesis
is that higher protein intakes are bad
as long as higher protein higher protein
intakes are different from lower protein
intakes in either direction
you could frame that as a bad thing and
again with magnitudes that are tiny
and don't as in some cases don't show up
at all until you load the model with
covariates
so and i'm not saying that the the
researchers
uh are doing anything wrong but i'm
saying from from an outsider who said oh
i guess kidney research exists i open up
the page
and i'm like well what do you guys want
it to do like if it goes up a little bit
or goes down a little bit you're like
yep
i knew it protein kidney failure yeah so
i i don't know maybe maybe a listener
can inform me about something i'm
missing out on there or just not picking
up on
well i mean i think one of the things we
can fairly confidently say
is if we're seeing if we're seeing
not much of a relationship between
theoretically the two variables we care
about protein intake and gfr
if we're not seeing much of a
relationship between those two variables
and then suddenly there becomes a strong
relationship between those two variables
when you put
a bunch of other covariates into the
model what that necessarily tells you
is those other covariates put into the
model are
not necessarily more likely to cause
changes in gfr
but are at least way way more strongly
associated with changes in gfr
than protein intakes are yeah at minimum
they're having a huge
moderating effect on protein's impact
and what that means is that the the
protein
viewed purely in isolation clearly is
not driving
this you know enormous uh
unstoppable effect on gfr values right
so in this particular paper again this
is
uh another instance where we look at the
crude model with no covariates versus
the
the model with covariates the crude
model
when they were looking at these four
different groups lowest to highest
protein intake
this is the annual rate of gfr reduction
minus 1.17 minus 1.28
minus 1.44 minus 1.26
the highest quartile protein group are
not quartile but the highest protein
intake that was divided up with these
thresholds based on grams per kilogram
had the second lowest rate of reduction
like just based on the raw numbers the
rate of reduction was worse in the
second and third group rather than the
fourth group with the highest protein
intake
now this is wild when you look at their
and the p
for the trend there that basically said
hey do we have this kind of linear
increase the p-value was 0.5
not 0.05 0.5 in a sample of
i mean thousands of people right i mean
if you have any like 2
200. yeah if you sample a 2200 you do
not need a big effect in order to get a
low p value
yeah now model two in this study they
had a number of different models with
different
groups of covariates but model two for
these same
numbers just adding the covariates in
when we look at the lowest to the
highest protein
groups and we're looking at the annual
rate of gfr reduction
now we're looking at minus 0.79 minus
1.12 minus 1.47
and minus 1.63 so
all of a sudden it becomes this huge
linear relationship keep in mind
the difference in that crude model
between the the best and the worst rate
of decline
was like i don't know about 0.3
adding in the covariates the value in
the first group
drops by over 0.3 and the value
uh or the magnitude i should say gets
smaller
so it's a smaller reduction year over
year
and then the change that we see in the
highest quartile group again
is over 0.3 in terms of the magnitude i
mean we're introducing changes to these
estimates
that are greater than the entire spread
from the crude model
those are huge changes in the effect i
mean
essentially what they're saying is like
other than
eating low protein people who eat low
protein do
everything possible to [ __ ] up their
kidneys and other than eating high
protein
people who eat high protein do
everything possible to preserve their
kidneys like that
that's pretty much the only way that you
could wind up with
a shift in trend that extreme right yeah
yeah so you know wrapping things up here
i know we just went through a long
segment of reading a lot of numbers
which is you know as far as i can tell
optimal radio but
but i mean people ask about this all the
time and i think it it helps to actually
take a deep dive into it but
you know wrapping things up here most of
our listeners want to know
most people in the fitness world will
eating a high protein diet
necessarily impair my kidney function
and i don't see how you look at these
results and say oh definitely
when we look at the raw values from
these studies without the addition of
hey
you know what what's your income what's
your education status how many
drinks do you have per week and all this
other stuff when we just look at the raw
values that people who eat a lot of
protein don't seem to be any worse off
than the people who
who eat lower amounts of protein
the the the rates that we see in these
papers for gfr reduction from quartile
to quartile or from group to group
we don't really see big differences when
we look at those raw values
so obviously if you have a kidney issue
you should listen to your doctor
there are doctors that specialize in
kidney function that is where you get
your information from
if you have a kidney condition pathology
disease
etc and i should be clear that there are
some
kidney conditions for which a high
protein diet is contraindicated it is
inadvisable it will exacerbate
reduc pre-existing reductions in kidney
function
but what we see you know based on the
literature i've looked at from
for people who have you know good kidney
function who have healthy kidneys with
no underlying pathology
we might see some functional adaptation
and some morphological adaptation when
you adopt a high protein diet we might
see
small changes within the normal range
when it comes to gfr
and when it comes to like i said the
actual morphology of the kidney
but adaptation is not always necessarily
pathological
there are plenty of adaptations our body
makes that are simply
to adjust to what we are doing so the
fact that we see a little fluctuation of
some metric within the normal range is
not necessarily
reason to panic um so
for people with otherwise healthy
kidneys these data just
are not convincing enough to me that i
would think oh you need to abandon a
high protein diet
um but like i said if kidney function is
a concern of yours
you know go see your doctor find someone
who who is really good with kidneys
it's good whenever you go see a doctor
to
um feel them out a little bit in terms
of like hey
you're doing a creatinine-based test
have you considered that i'm very
muscular and i eat a lot of animal
protein and i lifted six hours ago
like it's good to make sure that your
doctors seem pretty sharp and on top of
things
but uh but generally speaking when you
have a health concern like this go see a
doctor
uh and and ultimately defer to them yeah
and i mean ultimately
like if you want to simplify that
process just ask them how much they
bench
like if it's anything below 225
find a new doctor absolutely and that's
kilos
yeah um all right greg you had a
research review about uh
cholesterol right yeah so uh we're doing
everything possible
in this episode of the podcast to make
sure we get shut down by
by the american medical association uh
so
let's uh let's talk about uh cholesterol
and
whether dietary cholesterol intake might
help you get
jacked so the thing that uh kind of
precipitated me looking into this
is there was a paper that was uh epub to
had a print
a while back uh that was finally
published in an issue
um by bhagiri and colleagues titled
comparison of whole egg versus egg white
ingestion
during 12 weeks of resistance training
on skeletal
muscle regulatory markers in resistance
trained men
and so basically what they did is they
had subjects
lift for 12 weeks uh split them into two
groups
one of the groups consumed six egg
whites
after all of their workouts and the
other group consumed three whole
eggs after their workouts so that should
be
roughly matched for protein intake but
you know
one of the groups is only consuming egg
whites and the other one is
consuming yolks and everything that is
in
egg yolks including a lot of dietary
cholesterol
so in terms of
you know kind of headline results that
people would care about
things looked pretty similar overall um
so they assessed
changes in fat mass uh they looked at
skeletal muscle mass which i believe
they were assessing
uh via bioelectrical impedance which
isn't particularly great but whatever
it is what it is uh and they were
looking at changes in squat and bench
press strength
so the only significant difference
between groups in terms of those
outcomes
were that fat mass decreased
to a significantly greater extent in the
group
consuming whole eggs after their
workouts but it wasn't a particularly
large difference
so the whole egg group lost about two
kilos of fat
versus about 1.1 kilos in the egg white
group
the differences for every other measure
weren't uh statistically significant
but they did all kind of lean in favor
of consuming the whole
eggs versus the egg whites um
so for skeletal muscle mass which again
take with a grain of salt because
it wasn't assessed the best way possible
we all know
gold standard is the bod pod um
the increase in the whole egg group was
3.4 kilos versus 2.8
in the egg white group uh increase
in bench press strength also it was like
a couple kilos better
in the whole egg group uh kind of low
but not super low p
value about point two so probably not
worth really
reading into very much for the squat uh
there was it was actually like
relatively close
to being uh statistically significantly
different between groups p-value of
about .06
uh but it seems like the groups had
relatively homogeneous
increases because the actual raw
difference wasn't particularly large it
was about two or three kilos
um so anyway not much to write home
about
uh in this particular study so
you know if if you wanted to to
go with like the traditional
interpretation of p values
you would say like oh maybe consuming
whole eggs might have a slight
beneficial effect on body composition
uh but really for strength gains and
hypertrophy
not a ton of difference but you could
also look at it and say like well
maybe there's some other stuff slightly
leaning in favor of consuming whole eggs
um and so the the reason i wanted to
talk about this study
isn't necessarily because the results of
this study
itself are all that exciting but because
it
is as far as i'm aware the first
longitudinal study looking at the
effects of either whole egg intake
or uh cholesterol intake um
like the effects of those things on
strength gains or hypertrophy
in healthy young people however
there is some potentially interesting
uh longitudinal research on older people
and acute research on younger people
that
we can bring to bear on the question of
whether cholesterol intake
might affect strength gains and
hypertrophy
so one thing to note is that
uh when i talk about whole egg
consumption or cholesterol consumption
i'm gonna be using those two things
basically interchangeably
um so in some of these studies the
actual intervention being done the
manipulation being done
was having people eat whole eggs versus
egg whites or adding whole eggs into
their diet
some of them just looked at kind of
normal consumption of dietary
cholesterol within people's diets
the thing about that is like if you're
going to experimentally study
the impact of cholesterol on something
whole eggs are a very
good vehicle to give people cholesterol
because there's
a shitload of cholesterol and egg yolks
and if you're just looking at kind of
cross-sectional cholesterol intake in
people's normal diets
that's going to correlate very strongly
with whole egg intake because there is
certainly dietary cholesterol in other
foods but it's
it's present in egg yolks and probably
the greatest density of
virtually anything in like a normal
human diet
eggs are like nature's cholesterol
supplement yeah really the only other
thing you could put in that conversation
i think are shrimp
interesting we'll we'll fact check that
we'll get to the bottom of it
um all right so let's uh let's look at
some of the other
whole egg and cholesterol related
literature so
there was a 2017 study by van vliet and
colleagues that's
not fred vanvleet who plays for the
toronto raptors this is a different
vanvleet
um and this one got shared around kind
of in the
quote unquote evidence-based social
media space when it was published
the title is consumption of whole eggs
promotes greater
stimulation of post-exercise muscle
protein synthesis
than consumption of iso-nitrogenous
amounts of egg whites and young men
and so this was a crossover study they
had 10 resistance-trained men
put them through a workout and post
workout they either gave them whole eggs
or egg whites crossover study so the
same subjects
did both conditions and both
both conditions were matched for 18
grams of protein
they looked at a whole bunch of
different just general anabolic
signaling markers and all of those
were more or less similar between groups
but they also looked at muscle protein
synthesis
in the five hours following the workout
and it was considerably greater
when the subjects consumed the whole
eggs instead of the egg whites so
with whole egg consumption there was an
increase in muscle protein synthesis of
approximately 2.7 fold
versus about 1.9 fold increase with egg
whites
so one potential explanation for that is
like well there's
a lot of stuff in whole eggs that isn't
in egg whites and
total caloric intake was greater when
they were consuming the whole eggs
and that's true however if you're
looking at relatively acute muscle
protein synthesis
the additional calories in whole eggs
come predominantly from fat
that's present in the yolks and
generally fat content slows down the
digestion
and absorption of protein and so if
you're looking at relatively acute
muscle protein synthesis
you might actually hypothesize that by
adding some fat into the mix
you might see lower rates like lower
cumulative rates of
mps over just a five hour window um so
i i think it's interesting and somewhat
striking that
whole egg intake did promote increases
in muscle protein synthesis
even over a relatively short time scale
so let's move on to another study this
one is by lee and colleagues from 2011.
title is dietary cholesterol effects
skeletal muscle protein synthesis
following acute resistance training
and this one was just a conference
abstract so
uh there's not really a ton of
information about it and i'm not exactly
sure how they did their analysis
but i'm pretty sure what they did is
they had
two separate groups of untrained adults
so this wasn't a crossover study
and they had one of the groups of adults
consume a relatively high dietary
cholesterol intake for 10 days
prior to a training session so about 800
milligrams per day
of dietary cholesterol and another group
consume a low cholesterol diet for 10
days prior to a training session and
that was
less than 200 milligrams of cholesterol
per day
on the 10th day both groups did a
unilateral
training session and i think essentially
what they were doing
was comparing rates of muscle protein
synthesis in the trained leg
versus the untrained leg within each
group and then comparing those
differences between groups
and in this study they were looking at
cumulative rates or cumulative muscle
protein synthesis
over 22 hours post training so basically
for
for like how much how much new
muscle protein did they synthesize in a
day
uh after the training session uh and
what they found is there was a
significantly greater difference in
muscle protein synthesis
between the trained leg and the
untrained leg in the high cholesterol
group than the low cholesterol group
i didn't see a direct comparison of
muscle protein synthesis between groups
but this was interpreted to mean that
post-training
the elevation in muscle protein
synthesis in the trained tissues
was basically promoted to a greater
extent in subjects
who preceded their workout with 10 days
of relatively high
cholesterol intake
moving on to some uh
to some longitudinal studies uh there
was a study
by reichman and colleagues in 2007
i believe this was also only published
as a conference abstract i don't think
there's full text for it
but it was actually an rct which
again is weird that this wasn't
published because most
most like nutrition and training rcts do
end up getting published
but they had three groups of people um
they were older they were between 50 and
69 years old
one of the groups was assigned to
consume zero eggs per day
so they ended up with a pretty low
cholesterol intake less than 200
milligrams per day
another group was assigned to consume
one egg per day so they wound up with a
relatively
moderate cholesterol intake about 400
milligrams per day
and a third group was assigned to
consume three eggs per day so they wound
up with a relatively high cholesterol
intake of about
800 milligrams per day uh and all of
those
were mixed with a standard protein drink
so i think protein intake
was equated between groups or was
relatively similar between groups
and so what they had them do is train
for 12 weeks
they trained three times per week doing
eight exercises for
basically hypertrophy training so three
sets of eight to twelve reps per
exercise
um and they basically wanted to
see uh how that would affect accretion
of lean mass and also
gains in chest press and leg press
strength
so what they found is that after the 12
weeks of training
the group consuming no eggs increased
their lean mass by about two and a half
percent
the group consuming one egg increased
their lean mass by about
0.7 percent so basically no change and
the group consuming three eggs increased
their lean mass by about 3.6
so there was a significant difference
between one egg and three eggs but there
wasn't a significant difference between
zero eggs and three eggs so there's
there there was a slight trend if you
squint
just right for maybe the higher
cholesterol intake
uh promoting larger increases and lean
mass but that's
that's pretty weak because you know why
wouldn't one egg be better than zero so
i wouldn't put much stock in that
but as far as strength increases go the
zero egg and one egg group had
relatively similar increases in strength
about a 14 increase in combined chest
press and leg press strength
in the zero egg group and about an 8
increase in the one egg group
the three egg group on the other hand
had an increase of about 33 percent on
average
um so again not not like a clear linear
dose response relationship by any means
because nominally the one egg group
also did worse than the zero egg group
but the three egg group did have
um pretty substantially larger strength
increases than the other two groups did
um so that's again somewhat noteworthy
not
not super super strong evidence in favor
of higher cholesterol intakes but
uh at least on a nominal basis the three
egg group did
tend to do better than the other two
groups did
moving on again a 2009 study by igle and
colleagues titled
moderately increased protein intake
predominantly from egg sources
does not influence whole body regional
or muscle composition responses to
resistance training in
older people so in this study there were
36 subjects
average age early 60s had subjects
trained
three days per week for 12 weeks
and in this one unfortunately they
weren't just manipulating
whole egg or cholesterol intake it also
had an effect on total protein intake so
there was one group
consuming a relatively low protein
omnivorous diet so consuming about 0.9
grams of protein
per kilo of body mass per day and then
another group was consuming a higher but
still relatively low protein diet of
about 1.2 grams per kilo per day
and the difference in that protein
intake was achieved by adding eggs
into the higher protein groups diet
so they wound up with relatively large
differences in total cholesterol intakes
that the lower protein group
was consuming about 213
milligrams of cholesterol per day versus
about 610
for the higher protein group and the big
picture results of this study
is um much like the
recent paper by bugari that just came
out in younger people
there weren't any significant
differences between groups for really
any of the things that they looked at
but
for both gains and lean mass
and losses in fat mass there were
non-significant differences that leaned
in favor
of the group consuming higher protein
and higher cholesterol
and they also looked at changes in mean
fiber area so like fiber cross-sectional
area
and again there wasn't a significant
difference between groups in terms of
changes
in vastus lateralis mean fiber area
but there was an average 3.3 percent
increase
in the high protein high cholesterol
group and an average
5 percent decrease in the low protein
low cholesterol group
so again kind of hard to parse these
results you could either
you know strictly adhere to null
hypothesis significance testing and say
no significant differences nothing
nothing going on here nothing to look at
or you could say like in light of some
of the other things we've seen
maybe there were some slight differences
in favor of consuming
more cholesterol but again this study
unfortunately had
the additional confounder of the higher
cholesterol group
also consuming higher protein so you
know it's hard to know
if there were differences that the study
just was underpowered to detect
it's hard to say whether they were due
to cholesterol or due to protein
and finally this is probably this last
study is probably the one
that gets cited the most in relation to
the effects of cholesterol intake on
strength and or hypertrophy and notably
it is the first study
looking at the impact of cholesterol
intake on strength and or hypertrophy
so the title is statins and dietary
serum cholesterol are associated
uh er statins in dietary and serum
cholesterol are associated with
increased lean mass following resistance
training
by reichmann and colleagues and so
this study was not uh it wasn't an rct
basically what they did um is they had a
group
of 49 subjects aged 60 to 69 years old
and they had them trained for 12 weeks
they assessed
strength and changes in lean mass
and they collected dietary information
on them and
after the fact looked to see um
for people just naturally consuming less
cholesterol
like what were their strength and
hypertrophy responses relative to people
who were just naturally consuming
greater amounts of dietary
cholesterol and what they found is
that uh average dietary cholesterol
consumption was
like modestly associated with changes in
lean mass
they say strongly associated in the
paper the r value is like 0.45
i wouldn't call that a strong
association
but there was a positive there was a
significant positive association between
dietary cholesterol intake and changes
in lean mass
after adjusting for body mass and lean
mass levels of the subjects
that r value was slightly stronger so
about 0.5
the p-values for both of those are less
than .001 so that's
like a not a particularly strong
relationship but a
highly significant relationship um
and uh so yeah that's uh that's pretty
noteworthy and they also found
uh that the subjects consuming more
protein
or consuming more cholesterol weren't
really consuming
uh substantially different amounts of
protein than people consuming
less cholesterol uh so that's that's
good
and they also found that higher levels
of cholesterol intake were associated
with greater strength gains
so the subjects with the highest
cholesterol intake which was
um 7.2 to 10.2 milligrams
per kilogram of lean mass per day uh had
increases in chest press and leg press
of about 88
um versus uh about 41
for the subjects consuming the least
dietary cholesterol which
i think was less than 2.7 milligrams per
kilogram of lean mass per day
and also they looked at appendicular
lean mass gains and that was also quite
a bit greater
in the subjects consuming uh the highest
level of cholesterol versus the lowest
level so
about an 11.8 percent increase versus
about a 2.6 percent increase
um so
the results of that study were pretty
striking and in terms of of raw
differences i think the
like there's a figure in the study that
you can look at that
like shows the lean mass accretion on a
per group basis and
you can see these little uh these little
uh histograms and it's just like you
know
the the lowest cholesterol intake has
the smallest histogram and then it's
bigger and then it's bigger and then
it's the biggest
uh in the group consuming the most
cholesterol in terms of raw
differences and lean mass accretion
between the highest and lowest
cholesterol consumption in terms of lean
mass gain it was like basically no
change
in the group consuming the least
cholesterol and it was uh about like a
a five pound increase give or take in
the group consuming the highest
cholesterol which
is uh like quite a bit of hypertrophy
for subjects who are in their 60s
training for just 12 weeks
and so the results of that paper are are
pretty striking
and so i've seen discourse
around cholesterol intake go one of two
different ways
one way is that it just doesn't happen
um
there there seem to be a lot of people
who haven't even pondered the question
of whether dietary cholesterol intake
uh could affect hypertrophy and or
strength gains
and then there are some people i've seen
and
i myself was previously included in this
group
um who advocate for cholesterol intake
potentially being
very very important for hypertrophy and
strength gains
um and the thing is like when you
s when you zoom out and look at this the
totality of this research
the that first study by reichman was
very very striking they found a
significant linear relationship between
cholesterol intake and hypertrophy
the figures look pretty striking they
found relationships for both hypertrophy
and strength
and the thing is every other paper on
the subject that has been published
since then
is generally positive
so you know it ranges from
acute studies that find um
that find that things like muscle
protein synthesis are acutely elevated
by whole egg consumption to a greater
extent than egg white consumption
there's that other reichmann study that
was only published as an abstract that
found more hypertrophy and greater
strength gains with
consumption of three eggs versus one uh
and and there are
the studies by igle uh and the most
recent study by bugari and young people
um and you know they basically find
not many significant differences between
higher and lower cholesterol consumption
or
whole egg versus egg white consumption
but all of the non-significant
differences that exist
do kind of lean in favor of consuming
higher cholesterol
or whole eggs versus egg whites and so
it's one of those things where
overall i would say the literature is
pretty
positive but not nearly as strong
as that first study by reichman would
indicate
i'm getting a little bit ahead of myself
i i think it's first
worth noting why one might potentially
hypothesize that higher cholesterol
intake might be beneficial for
hypertrophy
um so there are three mechanisms i've
seen
proposed so one is that cholesterol
increases cellular rigidity
so your your cell membranes uh
what do they call it an anp a liquid
mosaic
isn't that what they say i think so yeah
so
yeah there's you have your phospholipids
and a bunch of proteins and various
carbohydrates and they can all just kind
of like flow around and just kind of
vibe
uh and the more cholesterol that is
inserted into the cell membrane it
basically
decreases how well everything else can
flow and that
increases the rigidity of the membrane
and so
if you are someone who thinks that
muscle damage might be associated with
hypertrophy
if you increase cellular membrane
rigidity of the sarcolemma
that should at least to some degree
promote
more sarcolemmal disruption and tissue
damage
so if you think that there is a
relationship between damage and
hypertrophy
greater cholesterol intake might
increase muscle damage which
then might increase hypertrophy i'm
pretty skeptical of that
explanation another proposed mechanism
by which cholesterol might improve
hypertrophy
is the opposite so increasing rates of
cellular repair after damage
so when tissues are damaged uh
cholesterol is deposited to then help
stabilize the area that was damaged and
aid and repair
um and so like you know maybe you can
have your cake and eat it too you can
get more damage and you can also repair
the damage quicker and
bada bing bada boom you get huge um
i think that the um
so it would be relatively easy to study
whether higher cholesterol intakes do
um help with damage repair after
training like
you could put people through a very
strenuous eccentric training protocol
give one group of people you know a
protein supplementation
a protein supplement post training give
another group of people
a supplement with protein intake and
also cholesterol that they consume post
training
and basically look to see whether uh
various markers of muscle damage
decline quicker in the group that also
consume the cholesterol
so that's something that could be
studied it sounds at least somewhat
plausible to me but i
i'd like to see direct research on it
personally
and then the other proposed mechanism
for higher cholesterol intakes
promoting hypertrophy is that they could
help with the
production of what are called lipid
rafts
um and so this this is a direct quote
from
old wikipedia it has been proposed that
lipid rafts are specialized membrane
microdomains
which compartmentalize cellular
processes by serving as organizing
centers for the assembly of
signaling molecules allowing a closer
interaction of protein receptors and
their effectors
to promote kinetically favorable
interactions necessary
for the signal transduction so basically
the idea being that
um like you have a bunch of receptors on
the outside of
like really every cell of your body that
includes muscle cells
the idea being that lipid rafts are
basically an area where
a lot of that stuff could be done in the
same place
and cholesterol is one of the molecules
that helps hold those lipid rafts
together
the wikipedia page also said that uh the
very existence of lipid rafts is
controversial that not everyone agrees
that they even exist
so i'm also putting that in in the i'm
skeptical category so
you know ultimately i think that the
if if cholesterol intake helps with
muscle damage repair
and that might help people you know
recover better train a little bit harder
um you know there there's research from
mcmaster
showing that um if you have high levels
of muscle damage the muscle protein
synthesis taking place
might be you know more directed towards
repairing damage
versus actually you know building more
contractile tissue and growing your
muscles so
you know if this helps uh more quickly
and maybe more efficiently repairing
muscle damage that might
allow the muscle protein synthesis that
takes place to be
kind of used more efficiently or you
know maybe you do actually get
uh consistent increases in muscle
protein synthesis as
uh as that one acute study from from
2017 by van vliet
would indicate so you know there are
some potential mechanisms here i
wouldn't consider any of them slam dunks
personally
and i would want to see the damage
repair potential mechanism
be directly studied first personally
but you know basically there is there is
some degree of potential mechanistic
rationale here
um so my my general take on this body of
research
as i indicated before is that you know
there's one very striking study and then
there's
a lot of other either acute studies with
generally positive results or
longitudinal studies with
uh generally positive but not
particularly
eye-popping results so i would say that
um number one it's hard to say whether
these results are driven by cholesterol
per se
or other things in egg yolks so you know
again there's a shitload of cholesterol
and egg yolks but there's also a
shitload of other stuff in
egg yolks um and you know it could just
be something else in egg yolks that
might be driving
some of these things we're seeing might
not be cholesterol per se
uh jury's still out on that because
again cholesterol intake and egg intake
are
are currently married together in that
body of research because
you know up to this point you wanna you
wanna have people consume more
cholesterol
you give them egg yolks um you know
that's just the experimental model
that's typically used
second thing is uh like i said the
results are positive overall
but it's noteworthy that the strongest
evidence in favor of cholesterol
promoting hypertrophy
comes from the first study ever
published in that area
uh which again was was a um like
quasi-observational study like they
didn't
they didn't proactively manipulate
cholesterol
intake like that's something they just
kind of found after the fact
uh and that's noteworthy because there's
a
um like there's something in the
literature
uh called the first finder effect where
basically
in any body of literature generally the
first
study that finds a particular effect
the magnitude of the effect tends to be
larger than the rest of the literature
basically once a body of literature
starts developing
uh and the reason for that is mostly
that
um you know if you're doing novel work
and you're like hey these two things
might be associated or like thing a mic
calls thing b and you do a study and you
have
a very very large positive striking
result
then that's going to get people excited
people are going to take notice and
they're going to say hey
we should research this as well
and if you either don't get a
significant result
or if it's just like you know kind of a
weak result
maybe you don't even publish it or maybe
if you do publish it it doesn't really
get much traction
so basically just like bodies of
research are more likely to grow up
around a first
very large positive effect
and things that that don't really pan
out are just less likely to get
published in the first place
um so we might be seeing the first
finder effect here where reichmann
you know through no fault of his own
found that
cholesterol maybe had a larger impact on
hypertrophy than it actually does
you know just purely due to sampling
variability whatever
um and maybe it does have a positive
effect but not as large as
the original reichmann study would
indicate um
so that that's a second thing to point
out third thing
is um or kind of my third take here is i
do think dietary cholesterol
might be a meaningful ergogenic but
again i'm skeptical about
whether the effects are particularly
large
certainly as large as the original
reichmann study would indicate
um i i do kind of think
that if you you know go from consuming
basically no dietary cholesterol to
a little bit of dietary cholesterol a
moderate amount
that might help with hypertrophy and
maybe strength gains there's nothing in
the literature to this point that
indicates that it wouldn't
and there's enough positive or kind of
positive results
and a complete lack of negative results
uh so so i do think that it might be
somewhat beneficial but
again i i wouldn't you know i wouldn't
bet the farm on it being
as big of a positive as say like
creatine is for example
um let's see another thing to note is we
don't know
and i think this is important we don't
know what the dose response relationship
looks like um between hypertrophy and
cholesterol intake if we assume that
there is one
and i think this is important because
the first
reichman study that found that
relatively striking
linear relationship the highest
cholesterol intake in that study
was 10.2 milligrams per kilogram
so you know you can't necessarily
extrapolate past that
in that study the follow-up study
comparing
zero egg one egg and three eggs per day
um
the highest cholesterol intake in that
study was 14 milligrams per kilogram and
they found that that might be beneficial
higher intakes than that haven't been
studied um
so you know it's one of those things
where we have some degree of evidence
that
up to you know 10 maybe 14 milligrams
per kilogram
of dietary cholesterol per day is
potentially beneficial
for hypertrophy and maybe strength gains
and the thing is
we don't know how far that extends to
you know it could be that like
you get above 15 you don't get anything
else from it
it i'm not saying that i think this but
it
is at least possible that maybe with
very high levels of dietary cholesterol
intake there is
a much more noteworthy hypertrophy
response or
it promotes hypertrophy to a to a
meaningfully greater extent
the thing is we can't say that from the
literature not because there's evidence
saying that even higher intakes aren't
beneficial but just simply
even higher intakes haven't even been
studied so we
we currently have no idea what the dose
response relationship
looks like past about 14 milligrams per
kilogram
uh fifth thing that i'll just say
personally
um is that i've noticed that my training
tends to go better when i'm eating a
fair amount of eggs
uh you know that's an anecdote n equals
one
do with it as you will um but yeah i've
i do tend to find that i recover from
training better
and generally have better results when
i'm eating a fair amount of eggs which
i'll note
um you know just is kind of a
check your bias uh situation here
i wish that weren't true because i don't
particularly like
eggs i don't want people to come out
like come away from this segment
thinking
greg is chilling for big eggs because he
loves
eggs and he wants this to be true i
don't actually like eggs very much
and i i actually like
meaningfully eat more eggs than i want
to
because of how much better it makes my
training feel
but again you know don't put too much
weight on that that is
purely my n equals one observation
uh and the last thing i'll just say kind
of to wrap this up
is the relationship between dietary
cholesterol
and serum cholesterol levels and or
heart disease
probably isn't as direct as people used
to say up until recently
i think either the american heart
association or the american medical
association or the world health organs
organization one of those or maybe all
of them or nasa
or nasa who knows yeah but but like one
one or multiple of those big
organizations have recently come out in
the last two or three years and
basically said like hey look
saturated fat probably still not great
but dietary cholesterol doesn't actually
affect your blood lipids as much as we
thought it did
anyway don't take my word for it i'm not
a [ __ ] cardiologist
uh if you're worried about dietary
cholesterol intake
talk to your doctor you know go to the
american heart association
go to the world health organization
whatever like trust
trust their take on that i again my
what i have seen indicates that dietary
cholesterol probably isn't particularly
deleterious for heart health uh unlike
serum cholesterol but
you know talk to a doctor about it yeah
if memory serves i remember
not long ago one of the more recent
rounds of the
u.s government dietary guidelines
they if memory research if memory serves
i think they just removed
their cholesterol recommendation it used
to be like hey limit it to no more than
300 milligrams per day or something like
that
and i i swear i i think they just
removed it and didn't say anything
just like i i feel like they were just
like
if we just don't make any statement
about it we don't necessarily have to
say either way whether or not it's
impactful
i'm pretty sure in one of the rounds of
dietary guidelines that comes out every
five years
it just like vanished and i think they
hoped nobody was going to ask him about
it
but uh i did some fact checking they
didn't want to wind up with egg on their
face
pun intended oh man that's a good joke
this is a really good joke
so uh a little bit of fact checking
i wouldn't say that you are a propagator
of fake news
oh god um is is it the shrimp
yeah no it's it's fine like i said it's
it's not fake news
uh eggs boiled 100 grams serving
google's telling me 373 milligrams
and for shrimp for 100 grams of cooked
shrimp we're talking about 189.
so that's still a high cholesterol food
but but definitely eggs are
seem to be very much in a class of their
own in terms of
reasonable serving size and the uh the
cholesterol
provided yeah okay now greg we're
we're pretty far into the episode here
so we've got some q and a's to do
do you have uh do you have any feelings
about cholesterol
i i've i feel like i'm not just
out on a limb but very close to the end
of a limb
uh because like nutrition's not my thing
and cholesterol is kind of like a
sub-area of nutrition that is even less
my thing
so as someone who knows things about
nutrition uh
do you think that i'm just like
massively off base
no i mean i i'll be honest cholesterol
is not something that's ever gotten me
super excited um it's not something i've
ever looked
looked into that closely
there was once a time where i was kind
of more interested in
you know how does dietary cholesterol
actually impact blood cholesterol levels
and you know
back in the day 80s and 90s they would
treat it like just a
very simple one-to-one ratio you put
more in all of a sudden your blood's
full of cholesterol
and certainly they've changed their tune
about that but that was as far as i ever
took it i never back when i was really
into the whole nutritional biochemistry
stuff
especially like during undergrad when i
would do a lot more studying than a
normal sane person would do
i was really into it but you know when
it comes to
hypertrophy and strength i've really
never looked into that
uh into that particular connection
but uh anyway like i was saying we've
got q and a's coming up here
let's do it we gotta be quick we got to
be
short to the point with responses
because we're running
way high on time all right so eric your
first question is from matt
who asks is there a simple way to judge
if i'm gaining too much fat on a bulk
how much weight gain is too much because
i feel like i gain
more muscle at the start of a bulk and
more fat towards the end
uh and i gain weight much faster at the
start
in the past i haven't considered
metabolic adaptation really so
could this be why i don't really think
it's
a metabolic adaptation thing um
but you know the the question is there a
simple way to judge
if you're gaining too much fat on a bulk
uh
you know i think it really comes down to
your goals and your preferences
so like when it comes to how much is an
acceptable amount of fat gain during a
bulk
ultimately that's going to depend on
where you feel your best where you
perform your best and where you look
your best
and kind of how you prioritize those
different things in a bulk so
an optimal bulk for a defensive lineman
is going to look very different from the
optimal bulk
for a natural bodybuilder these are very
very different things
now general advice for rate of weight
gain um
if you want to push the pace a little
bit and let's say you've got plenty of
weight you're trying to put on you're
not trying to gain that last
you know two pounds to hit your genetic
ceiling but you're getting started or
you think you've got a solid 20 25
pounds to gain
maybe gaining 0.25 to 0.5 percent of
your body weight per week
that's on the more aggressive end of the
spectrum if you are really conservative
about it you really want to minimize fat
gain or you just really don't have that
that far to go before you hit your kind
of genetic ceiling
in terms of lean mass then you want to
go slower with it so
0.25 percent of body weight per week or
or much lower
depending again on your tolerance for
fat gain but you know i don't think it's
easy to give a
a metric about you know how much is is
too much
it really just comes down to what is the
purpose of this bulk and what is our
tolerance for
for fat gain of course the quicker you
go the more likely you're going to see a
higher percentage of
of weight gained as fat rather than lean
mass so that's something to keep in mind
if you're very concerned about the
relative proportion of fat gain i would
advise going as slow as you can
essentially
tolerate you know so the slower the
better but ultimately if we're going too
slow then we're not making big strides
toward the goal so
it's the same thing with weight loss you
know weight loss we generally see better
outcomes when we take it nice and slow
but
you know if you're losing a kilogram a
year you're probably not going to get to
that end goal in a reasonable time frame
so one of the things that comes up here
like i said i don't think metabolic
adaptation has much to do with it i mean
we do see
metabolic adaptation going the other
direction so
when we when we try to ramp up calories
a lot of times we will see that total
energy expenditure increases
to kind of accommodate for that that
varies a lot from person to person
so there have been some cool over
feeding studies where they really over
feed people
in a highly controlled atmosphere so
they can get really really good numbers
from the study
some people have really large adaptive
responses to overfeeding
and we know these people right so like
when you were when you were in high
school and your buddy would just like
eat like crazy and never gain weight
like
you probably know people that have a
really a really market
uh adaptive response to overfeeding
other people aren't quite as
as i mean i don't know if you even say
it's lucky or unlucky it really just
depends on your set of goals but
other people when they over feed they
don't have a big adaptive response and
they gain weight
quite readily the proportion of how much
of that is fat mass or lean mass is
going to depend
do they have a good training stimulus in
place to uh to promote muscle mass
how fast are they gaining the weight in
general so there's a lot of factors to
consider there but
one of the things i don't think
metabolic adapt adaptation is a
main concept to focus on here but one of
the things i would focus on
is that a lot of people seem to suggest
that
staying leaner is going to enhance your
hypertrophy
and it seems that a lot of people hang
their hat on this idea that insulin
sensitivity is driving that relationship
and i it's one of those things that i
see talked about a lot
never with any supporting evidence
behind it it's like
a lot of people have accepted this to be
true but whenever i'm like
oh here's a discussion about this again
there are not a lot of links being
shared
to actual evidence so you know i've seen
a lot of people with really high body
fat
putting on a ton of muscle uh for
example
any sumo athlete any offensive lineman
any defensive lineman the idea that
having high body fat
is going to necessarily be a super
heavyweight power lifter
any super heavyweight power every super
heavyweight strong man
yeah i mean every super heavyweight
weightlifter yeah i mean
fat free mass index generally correlates
with body fat percentage my boy lasha
is not shredded if if you look at all of
the
biggest individuals on the planet with
the most fat free mass
they tend not to be shredded okay and
shredded people are where we find the
high insulin sensitivity
so i i don't understand
i haven't seen a solid basis uh for this
particular contention i haven't seen
anybody really put together
a a really solid argument to support
this
but what i have seen is that my eyes
tell me that there's a
if you if you were to take a random
sample of the most muscular athletes on
the world
in the world they're generally not going
to have a low body fat percentage
so sometimes i see people get wrapped up
in this idea and they say
do i need to get really shredded so i
can do a successful bulk
and i just don't see any reason to
believe that that would be the case
i mean when it comes to cutting before
bulking
it's not about insulin sensitivity and
by the way
yes muscle cells will become more more
responsive to insulin but so will fat
cells
you know when we get leaner so uh it's
not this like
one directional unidirectional
relationship where
if you get shredded all of a sudden all
nutrients are going to go to muscles
because of insulin sensitivity i mean
adipose cells adipocytes they like
insulin too
they respond to it as well so
the the only reason you would really
want to get lean before a bulk is
because you don't want to spend your
time bulking
while having a high body fat percentage
either due to health reasons
performance reasons or body image
reasons but uh
but yeah the uh in terms of deciding how
much
fat is too much fat during a bulk or
what is a an appropriate body fat
percentage to maintain during your bulk
it's completely
up to your preferences and completely up
to to what you're comfortable
with and what your uh what your
priorities are
can i just drop in an anecdote in here
sure
so first statement is not anecdotal uh
there is
there is some research looking at um
like post
exercise or either post exercise or post
protein consumption
uh rates of muscle protein synthesis in
uh relatively lean versus relatively not
lean
uh untrained people that tends to
indicate that like people who are
who are quite obese um might not have
as much might not have as large of a
muscle protein synthetic response
um which might be related to just kind
of like
general poor health um
it might be kind of comparable to to i
think what we've talked about in older
people before
uh anabolic uh insensitivity
so um one of the things that i've
noticed
in clients that i've trained previously
people who are
untrained um relatively obese and
probably not in great health
is that some of them do tend to do
better
starting out in not like a particularly
large deficit but like a fairly small
deficit
because one of the things that that we
do tend to see is that
when folks are overweight when they
start losing weight they don't have to
be in a particularly large
deficit and don't have to lose a ton of
weight
before a lot of markers in metabolic
health do tend to start improving like
fairly quickly um and so you know take
off
even maybe just like 5 or 10 pounds and
then suddenly they start responding to
training quite a bit better
and one of the things that differs
between uh
an obese untrained person and say a sumo
wrestler
is the sumo wrestler is doing a shitload
of exercise
um probably does still have relatively
decent insulin sensitivity
uh if they have high levels of baseline
inflammation it's probably not
necessarily due to their obesity but
more just because they're
training like a goddamn madman so one of
the things i've noticed
is that if if you start with like a
relatively
obese probably not in great shape person
it might not be a terrible idea to start
with a deficit for maybe like two or
three months just lose a little bit of
weight
and then they might respond better to
training from there but for someone
who's currently training and has been
training for a period of months or years
that's probably not something you need
to worry about all that much
that that's just my opinion and in
observation that i've had
so is it about getting to a specific
body fat level or
simply just being in a deficit uh i i
think it's more about just being in a
deficit
um oh man the uh
so some of the so i'm going to assume
that kind of the the anabolic
sensitivity stuff
probably correlates with just general
metabolic health to some degree
and the research on that i've seen tends
to indicate that
if someone can reach an approximately
five to ten percent reduction in body
weight or body fat uh
you know they're not going to be
perfectly metabolically healthy but
that's like
the magnitude of weight loss you need to
see for things to really start improving
in a pretty marked way um so yeah like
for for someone who's who's fairly obese
they don't have to get lean before
things start improving like
once they're in a deficit for a little
bit and lose a little bit of fat
a lot of those markers in metabolic
health do tend to start improving
relatively quickly and my observation
has been
in folks like that you get them to that
state and then they do start responding
to training quite a bit better
okay so we're really talking about kind
of two slightly different things here so
if someone is completely untrained and
they're in a state of
of poor metabolic health uh generally
speaking
and their long-term goal is to be big
and strong and lean
and all those things then of course i
could understand the first phase being
let's get into training you know let's
kind of develop a base here
and while we're doing that let's get in
a caloric deficit lose a little bit of
fat and get to a state where we just
have better
overall cardio metabolic health i think
that definitely makes sense but
that's a very different thing from
saying that having a high body fat
percentage uh
is necessarily prohibitive of increased
muscle gains
um you know those are two very different
concepts and
you know i think the issue is a lot of
people are starting to suggest that
you know having a high body fat
percentage in and of itself
necessarily uh prohibits you from
maximally gaining
a lean body mass during a bulk and i
just don't really see
a lot of evidence to support that and i
think more importantly that doesn't seem
to really be compatible with
just real world observations you know
getting back to what we were talking
about earlier when you look at
the drug-free human beings with the most
fat-free mass and the most lean body
mass
those are individuals that tend to have
high body fat levels so
if you know a certain threshold of body
fat percentage was
necessarily prohibitive of you know
allowing
gains in lean body mass then you would
expect things to look a little bit
differently when you look around at
the super heavy weight lifters of the
world and the sumo athletes of the world
and you know
everybody that competes in a sport where
they have a high body fat percentage
and also happen to have an absolute
enormous amount of fat-free tissue and
lean body mass
and muscle mass itself all right moving
on we've got a question from
jack ryan on facebook when we talk about
cns or central nervous system fatigue
what are we talking about
mechanistically
is there anything we can specifically do
to improve
cns recovery why do i always get sick
if i'm overly fatigued in terms of my
cns
yeah so um there are a couple different
things
we might be interpreting a cns fatigue
um but i think that most of it's not
uh i i think that most of what people
interpret as cns fatigue might not
necessarily be what a researcher would
interpret as cns fatigue
um so if we're talking about the cns the
central nervous system
that is the brain and spinal cord and so
when we're talking about the central
nervous system
and you know effects on force output and
performance you're
you're looking at things like motor
drive uh from the motor cortex
uh you know that does go down when
you're acutely fatigued from training
um you might potentially be dealing with
poor transmission
of motor impulses from the motor cortex
to corticospinal neurons
or you could potentially be dealing with
poor transmission
of motor impulses from corticospinal
neurons to peripheral
motor nerves uh which you know are then
what actually innervate the muscles
um so any of those things you could term
cns fatigue
and when people talk about cns fatigue
they're generally talking about
kind of generally feeling shitty and
performing poorly
and it being something that kind of
accumulates over time
where you know even on their off days if
they take two or three days off they
still don't feel good their performance
is going down
uh and all of those things that would
actually kind of be
cns fatigue don't really seem to behave
like that
um so if you do do some in doo doo
if you do some intense exercise uh you
know
you can see some decreases especially in
like central motor drive um but
generally like that's pretty well
recovered within
within hours and generally within
minutes so that's not really
um a prime candidate for what most
people
interpret as cns fatigue um
so then uh we could look at some
peripheral factors that might be
contributing
so uh when we talk about peripheral
factors contributing
to fatigue we're generally dealing with
failures of excitation contraction
coupling
so you know essentially you could be
dealing with
fewer neurotransmitters being released
from motor nerves
into the synaptic cleft you could be
dealing with a situation where it
requires
greater stimulation from the motor nerve
to get the sarcolemma of the muscle
fibers to depolarize in the first place
uh or you could be dealing with a
situation that even when the sarcoma
depolarizes and you get an action
potential
when that actually reaches the
sarcoplasmic reticulum
you wind up with less calcium release or
you could wind up
uh in in a situation where you have
decreased sensitivity to calcium
or just something else going on in the
muscles that are that that's
um negatively affecting the interactions
of your contractile proteins you're
acting in myosin
um and so i think that
there's probably some stuff going on
there that people
interpret as cns fatigue so let's start
with
with some peripheral factors that people
might be interpreting as cns fatigue
so there is a phenomenon termed
low frequency fatigue that i think is a
pretty decent candidate for what people
might interpret as cns fatigue and so
what low frequency fatigue is
essentially is
um if you have like a neuromuscular lab
setup what you can do
is you can look and see how hard muscles
will contract
if you uh basically stimulate them a
little bit
versus when you stimulate them a lot and
what low frequency fatigue is
is essentially you see a decrease in
muscle force output
when the muscles are stimulated a little
bit but when you stimulate them a lot
they
are still capable of contracting with
their maximum
possible force um and so
how you would probably perceive that is
uh you go to the gym your warm-ups feel
heavy your working sets move slow
um you know if someone put a gun to your
head and said like hey you have to hit
within three percent of your
you know previous one rep max you could
but like everything
just feels harder than it otherwise
should
um so that that's probably how you would
kind of feel and interpret low frequency
fatigue
um and there are several things that
could cause that it seems to mostly be
calcium driven
um so you know just a very very
basic background about how muscle
contraction works
uh you get a motor impulse depolarizes
the sarcolemma
that goes down to the sarcoplasmic
reticulum
you get calcium release into the into
the muscle fiber
um that interacts with troponin
tropomyosin
now your actin and myosin can interact
and muscle contraction takes place
that's all good
uh so ultimately you need uh calcium
release
to basically allow actin and myosin to
interact
and the more calcium release you get the
the more
basically the more actin and myosin can
come in contact with each other to
you know contract and and cause muscle
contraction
uh so if you get impaired calcium
release
that can uh or if you get
impaired calcium release with any given
kind of sub-maximal
level of muscle stimulation you wind up
with low-frequency fatigue so
you get maximum stimulation you still
you still can get enough calcium
into the muscle cell for maximum
contractions to take place
but basically it takes a greater
stimulus to get
a particular amount of calcium going on
in there so a couple things could
contribute to that
one of them could be localized glycogen
depletion so if you get
um if if the glycogen depletes around
the proteins that pump calcium back into
the sarcoplasmic reticulum
then basically at any time that fiber
would twitch you would get less
calcium being released each time so that
could be a factor but that's
probably not a main factor in what
people would interpret as cns fatigue
because
assuming you're eating a decent amount
of carbs that should more or less be
sorted out within about 24 hours of a
workout um
muscle damage can be a contributor here
so
if your sarcolemma is disrupted you you
basically
propagate action potentials less
efficiently
which could result in less calcium
release so that could be a factor
so you know if you're experiencing
something that feels like cns fatigue
after a particularly high volume
training cycle or after an increase in
training volume
you might just be dealing with muscle
damage and
muscle contraction not working as well
because of that
um and then what i think
what i think kind of one of the more
important factors is and what
the researchers tend to think one of the
more important factors is
is um when you do
repeated maximal contractions uh
basically you just wind up with a bunch
of calcium within the muscle fibers
and through a feedback mechanism which
i'm not even going to pretend like i
fully understand
if you already have a lot of calcium
present within the muscle fiber
uh every time depolarization happens
your sarcoplasmic reticulum releases
less
additional calcium into the muscle fiber
than it otherwise would
um and so essentially like that seems
like something that might take
hours to days to resolve and another
factor is that when you're
when you're dealing with a lot of
maximal contractions
you can get an accumulation of inorganic
phosphate within the muscle fiber
that interferes with the interactions
between actin and myosin so it can
mechanistically decrease force output
and something else that's theorized
is that when you have both of those
things going on just a fair amount of
calcium hanging out in the muscle fiber
and a fair amount of inorganic phosphate
they can kind of
link up and form calcium phosphate um
which is just like a [ __ ] and seems
like
it probably needs to be disassociated
again before
either the phosphate can be removed as a
waste product or recombined with adp
or creatine and the calcium can be you
know pumped back out of the muscle fiber
and that might be a process that takes
you know several days
so those are all local factors that
could
um increase
basically make everything feel harder
make everything feel heavier
that you might be interpreting as cns
fatigue
um and then another thing that would
act more centrally but wouldn't
necessarily be due
to um like decreases in central motor
drive or anything like that so it kind
of like a chicken versus egg thing
um is there is a model
of overtraining referred to the cytokine
hypothesis of overtraining which
to be clear now we understand that like
these things do happen but they're not
like the
only factor contributing to overtraining
so that this has kind of been
subsumed into kind of larger grander
theories of over training but but this
is something that contributes
so when you train hard um you get an
inflammatory response
and you get an immune response in
response to the inflammatory response
and monocytes will release pro
pro-inflammatory cytokines
including interleukin-1 beta
interleukin-6 and
tumor necrosis factor alpha or tnfa
um and all of those things can
promote further systemic inflammation uh
and so that that can do a couple things
one
uh it can make you just feel more
lethargic and fatigued so
just when you in general are more
inflamed
uh if you have like subclinical uh
inflammation that's affecting your cns
that makes you feel like [ __ ] uh and
also interleukin-1 beta
is the cytokine that
seems to do a lot of the heavy lifting
to make you feel like [ __ ] when you're
sick
um so like when you're sick your body
doesn't want you
doing a bunch of stuff and burning a
bunch of energy because it's trying to
preserve that energy for your immune
system to have enough energy to fight
off with whatever's infecting you
and so interleukin-1 beta is released
and that
makes you feel like [ __ ] and makes you
feel lethargic and not feel like doing
much
and so like if you're dealing with like
high cytokine levels in response to
maybe some degree of overreaching or
overtraining you get that same
pro-inflammatory cytokine interleukin-1
beta
and that can make you feel very
lethargic
um and again it wouldn't necessarily
impair performance if you were maximally
motivated to perform
but it can certainly make you not be
maximally motivated to perform
um and one of the things this question
noted as well is like when i'm
experiencing cns fatigue
i feel like i always get sick and so i
think that that
some of the cytokine hypothesis stuff is
going on here because one of the other
effects is when you're dealing with
especially chronically high levels of
these pro-inflammatory cytokines
that can um it initially like ramps up
kind of activation of your immune system
which then kind of fatigues it
uh and as a response you'll be more
likely to deal with
head colds and and things of the like so
you know not necessarily getting super
sick but just
kind of feeling really cruddy
and just because like you know slight
bacterial infections you might have been
able to more easily beat off before
[Music]
phrasing whatever we can leave it in
that you might have been able
to defeat before you know can now kind
of take a bit
of a greater foothold within your upper
respiratory tract and
uh you just feel kind of like [ __ ] um so
i
i kind of think that when people talk
about cns fatigue
they're probably thinking about a
combination of
high pro-inflammatory cytokine levels as
a result
of just high training volume and muscle
damage and and the like
uh and probably some of the low
frequency fatigue which is more
of a like local peripheral thing and not
necessarily cns related at all
um so i i think that those are the the
two biggest things going on in the
phenomenon that people
interpret as cns fatigue and if you want
to do something about it
it's pretty straightforward sleep plenty
eat plenty especially carbs again if if
some localized glycogen depletion is the
issue
and something else that seems to help
quite a bit is continuing to exercise
but make it easy in low intensity
um if you just sit around like a knot on
a log you will
uh eventually feel better but you'll
feel better a little bit quicker if
you're still doing
something but the something you're doing
isn't particularly hard
all right are we doing more uh
yeah what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna go
through some rapid fire questions for me
let's do it just to make sure we get
plenty of answers here
um okay so i got a bunch of different
questions i think
i think all of these are if not all of
them most of them came from the
stronger by science facebook group so
one person asked
is there any benefit to cycling your
creatine
a quick answer is no so it is true that
supplementing with typical doses of
creatine
can reduce uh short-term production of
creatine our endogenous creatine
production goes down a little bit
normally we make like a gram a day and
so if we are consuming five grams a day
that's naturally going to go down a
little bit but the good news is
that endogenous production kicks right
back into gear when you stop taking
creatine and creatine levels kind of go
back down to normal so
the only reason you would ever really
cycle creatine would be if you're just
tired of taking it and or maybe you're
tired of
spending money on it so you just run out
and don't buy more but
you know there's really no inherent
advantage to cycling creatine
another question was what's my take on
supplementing with leucine at every meal
to optimize muscle protein synthesis
um yarn trommelin doctor dramalin
wrote an article for stronger by science
back in the day about protein
he talked a little bit about that as
like a speculative method um
and the idea was that the post meal
increase in leucine uh is pretty
important for initiating maximal rates
of protein synthesis
and uh you know if we have a really big
dose of protein in a mixed meal
sometimes that uh digestion and
absorption rate of that protein is so
prolonged that we don't get that
immediately you know
huge spike in leucine i would say
it's probably unnecessary for the vast
majority of people
if you're eating plenty of protein
throughout the day
and kind of splitting it up between
three to five approximately equal sized
meals
you're probably getting what you need
out of your dietary protein but
you know if you're someone that
exclusively eats slow digesting proteins
or
really low leucine protein sources or
you're just not getting enough
total protein in general there might be
some modest theoretical
benefit of throwing some leucine in with
those meals but
for me it seems like the type of
intervention that would be a lot of
effort for either a modest
theoretical benefit or a an uncertain
theoretical benefit you know
it's not like a high probability huge
magnitude effect that you can
absolutely bank on by by going that
route
uh another question one other thing to
note we've seen tastes like [ __ ]
does it really i've never tried to
supplement with it it's [ __ ] terrible
yeah so when you're at bulk
supplements.com maybe get something with
some flavor to mix with that
yeah okay good um all right so
does the effect of citrulline malate
decrease with continuous
use i highly doubt it i don't see any
reason to believe why that would be the
case if anything i would expect
potentially uh you know repeated use
might be a little bit more advantageous
just from kind of chronically
upregulating the capacity for nitric
oxide production
but i see no reason to believe that that
we would see any kind of
habituation to the effect or reduction
of the magnitude of that effect
someone asked if you're supplementing
with collagen to help repair
soft tissue do you think it'd be
beneficial to
antagonize the problem areas during your
workouts to elicit
an inflammatory response so basically on
top of that collagen supplementation
trying to
also induce some inflammation and i i
think they were talking in the long form
of the the question about getting blood
flow to the area
so i know jason has talked about this
he's our um our physical therapist on
the stronger by science coaching team
and when you're coming back from you
know a tendon ligament soft tissue
type injury um you know doing some
having a training stimulus as part of
the plan is definitely a good idea
um it will stimulate blood flow to the
area but it doesn't seem that blood flow
is really a limiting factor
when it comes to the recovery of those
tissues and
you know inducing inflammation isn't
really the goal there
we want to provide a mechanical stimulus
that will
facilitate that recovery process it's
not necessarily
driven by inflammation or driven by
blood flow
and i would say you know we don't want
to be adding a huge training stimulus
that's going to over stress the tissues
and cause
a huge influx of of inflammation to the
area so
having a training stimulus mechanically
stimulating those tissues is a good idea
but it's not necessarily dictated by
blood flow or inflammation
and of course when we answer this
question we're talking about after the
acute injury phase so
you're going to have the acute injury
and there's going to be plenty of that
immediate inflammation and recovery that
has to take place and we're talking
you know basically beyond that acute
phase of recovery once we're starting to
look at the
long term kind of chronic recovery phase
after that acute
inflammation is pretty much cleared up
then you start adding in that training
stimulus and and it does have some
positive effects but again it's not uh
it's not that we need to manually go out
of our way to make sure blood's getting
delivered to those tissues
another question this one is for body
composition and performance purposes
what are my thoughts on behavior-based
dietary intervention so
rather than just saying hey here's some
macro targets carb fat and protein to
shoot for every day
you know giving more behavior stuff
let's minimize intake of these foods
let's maximize
intake of those foods you know try to
get this much water per day
not only do i think they're fine i think
for a lot of people they're better
than just saying hey here's some macros
to shoot for um
they're very very useful especially for
people who aren't used to macro tracking
and maybe
aren't really don't have full buy-in
when it comes to having that meticulous
level of control over
every single food that they're eating
throughout the day and so
from a coaching perspective the really
cool thing about these behavioral types
of adjustments or interventions
is you think about the macro change you
want to implement
and you find a behavior adjustment to
support that right so if you're thinking
i'd love to lower their carbs but
they're not really tracking and they're
not weighing their food and all that
stuff
then you think well what kind of
behaviors might help us
bring that change into the diet without
specifically tracking carbs so
instead of doing a reduction in their
carb target you say
let's increase some of these foods let's
minimize some of these refined sugars or
added sugars
and you can basically give some little
behavioral targets instead of numerical
targets that essentially
work to reduce carb intake so for a lot
of people not only are they totally
doable
but for a lot of people they're actually
better than focusing specifically on
numbers
and then finally should athletes focus
on cutting weight
in a caloric deficit be worried about
micronutrient deficiency
i mean really everyone should be mindful
of potential micronutrient deficiency
it's something that you should keep an
eye on especially if you have really low
calorie intake or
if you have a very low degree of food
diversity if you only eat like a few
main foods day in and day out you want
to take a look at those foods and make
sure that you don't have any major
gaps in your diet so there are some
people who just eat
really really simplistic diets who you
know they're not even on low calories
but there might be some glaring gaps in
their diet
in terms of key micronutrients so
generally speaking whether you're on
high calories or low calories you want
to have a variety of food sources
a multivitamin you know based on the
the studies out there it's kind of hit
or miss whether or not there's a benefit
but
i don't see a lot of major downsides to
having a well-formulated multivitamin in
the mix
especially if you're not if you're not
enthusiastic about
doing you know putting in that work and
looking at your diet really objectively
and kind of
tabulating the different micros i think
having a multivitamin in the mix never
hurts
uh of course adequate fat intake to make
sure that you're supporting the
absorption of fat-soluble vitamins
and then one thing that i do implement
when my calories get really low and my
fat gets really low
i think fish oil becomes more helpful in
those scenarios because
you know when you're talking about
having 40 45 50 grams of fat in a given
day
you want to be extra mindful of making
sure that you're actually getting your
essential fatty acids
so having some kind of a marine based
omega-3 supplement can be extra helpful
in those scenarios okay that's my rapid
fire got a bunch of questions answered
greg is there a particular question
you'd like to uh
to work in here nah i i think we can
push them off for the next the next
uh recording awesome so next episode
we'll probably have a bunch of
a bunch of q and a's to make sure that
we're staying on top of these
uh okay now to play us out we do have
one additional question from maddie
frazier
in the uh the facebook group this was
one that
we we put it in the to play us out
segment because it's not
necessarily super on topic
i don't know if there's a lot of
practical insight that listeners can
glean from this but the question
is given how you both train what's the
biggest
animal you think you could fight with
caveman
technology and actually win that fight
and we discussed this off the air and i
think we reached a pretty sensible
consensus so
why don't you you tell the good people
what that is yeah so
the the downfall of this question is it
didn't
uh put enough stipulations in place so
it just asked
what the biggest animal we could fight
was and not
uh where or how that fight would take
place
obvious answer blue whale but it's
beached
you know it's out of water it's a whale
out of water
as they say uh easiest fight
like are you kidding me you wouldn't
even have to do anything
um so yeah uh and you know
it doesn't even have to be beached it
could just be in the middle of the
savannah
it's not getting back to the [ __ ]
ocean are you kidding me like
it's the biggest animal that ever lived
so like
of course that's what we would pick an
easiest fight in the world
biggest that ever lived i think so wow
it is it's easy to forget like when you
think of
large sea creatures you just think oh
wow i'm sure it's pretty big
but it's easy to forget exactly how huge
they are
oh yeah they're absolutely enormous how
long do they get
cause like i've been at those like
natural history museums and you see the
little picture
of like a school bus that looks like a
little toy car uh
so the average length not the biggest
ever but the average
is about 24 meters or about 80 feet
good grief that is so big um
man a lot of whales in the show lately
you know a lot of whales
if you're a lifting fan and you like
nutrition but you
also like whales we've had you covered
the last few weeks
fun whale fact that we can just end with
i saw this headline
i wasn't going to do this for my good
news segment just because
i feel like we have had a little bit too
much whale content lately
um but it was so
and this this is also right in my
wheelhouse because it's something that's
like very depressing that has like a
slight silver lining
so uh actually this is this isn't even
that depressing
whatever i'll just come out and say it
uh so it was
it was a headline talking about how uh
whales
in the arctic uh have recorded you know
based on like patterns of whale song and
like how much they're having sex and
whatnot
uh scientists surmise that they are
having uh either their happiest or one
of their happiest years on record
um because there aren't as many cruise
ships going through
because of covet 19. and i was going to
say that's sad because of kovan 19 but
also like
cruises [ __ ] suck dude like i get i
guess i'm breaking one of my cardinal
rules and that i am yucking other
people's yums but
honestly i can't think of anything that
sounds more miserable than a cruise
uh one because i get very seasick and
two it's just like
dude if i'm going on vacation uh i want
to see the people who
i love and care about and then be able
to like severely limit my interactions
with anyone else
at least as much as i want to you know
what i mean yeah uh
being cramped up on a ship with like
hundreds of other people
uh who are also just like hardcore in
vacation mode
that sounds terrible i've never really
thought about that but but you do
raise some interesting points but i feel
like that's an industry we just don't
need to bring back
after covid we're going to lose all of
our uh
all of our cruise ship people um
that does bring me to a bigger point
though so you mentioned like the
kind of is this good news is it bad news
the good news segment is on notice like
it it is on the
on the verge of being cut because we
were looking at some good news stories
and and you you shared this on twitter
so people might already know this
but like on one of those like uh
websites that curates good news stories
like
i think this one was msn yeah yeah in
like their good news section right
yeah i mean right next to each other
by the same author uh you'll know better
than me
what were the headlines again uh one of
them is like
why being optimistic might be a bad
thing during covid and then
the next one is like uh how to stay
upbeat during coven
yeah it was like literally right next to
each other these completely
contradictory stories yeah
i've got it so uh first one is under the
life heading
happiness expert colon one technique for
staying upbeat during the pandemic
uh and then right next to it under the
health and wellness
subhead behavior experts say that
optimism could be unhelpful in a
pandemic
so so it's like here's how to be happy
and here's how it's gonna [ __ ] ruin
your life
yeah i mean between those mixed messages
and the fact that like
most of the good news stories are just
tragedies in disguise
yeah like like mine it's like oh like
happy for the dog it pulled through it's
not dead and guess what
whales are going extinct uh and the
dog's helping a little with that
yeah yeah so i don't know stay tuned we
might have to cancel
not just the good news segment but the
concept of good news i think it's out
on its way out you know i think we could
stick with it and just embrace the
darkness
like we we could present these things
that are framed as good news stories and
then
just talk about like how dark and
insidious all of the underlying
conditions
that allowed them to be published are
yeah like we could take a like a very
analytical approach to the good news
segment and be like let's really dissect
this and let's get to some of the key
principles here
okay good stuff so um i think that does
it for this week's episode uh
as always thank you for listening and we
will be back in a couple weeks
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs
for all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do
so we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description
of today's episode finally please
remember that we are not medical doctors
or registered dietitians so before you
make any changes to your exercise or
nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified
healthcare professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
[Music]
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you